but what we need to do is we need to
analyze what do we need to multiply by
to get rid of this cube root in the
denominator we just want something
without a radical well when you take the
cube root of something in order for it
to be a perfect cube root you need how
many of them you need three right so you
can see right now we've got one so what
we really need is we really need two
more of these axes so I'm going to
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by the cube root of x
squared so if I do that what I can see
now in the denominator is I have the
cube root of x times x squared which is
X cubed okay and the cube and the cube
root cancel one another out so that just
gives us X in the denominator so now
we've gotten rid of that radical in the
denominator so we're on the right track
but remember whatever you do to the
denominator you want to do to the
numerator because this is really like
multiplying by one so now if we multiply
we just get three cube root of x squared
all divided by X now you can't reduce
these because ones underneath this
radical here ones just you know outside
of the radical that's as far as we can
go so that's example a okay let's look
at an example B now here we have five
divided by the fourth root of 4x cubed
now you see this four here you can think
of this as two squared so four is really
two squared okay and so now what we're
trying to do is we're trying to get rid
of this radical in the denominator right
but remember in order to take a fourth
root of something you know you're
looking for groups of four of the same
quantity right here we've got two 2's
we've got three axes how many more of
these do we need to make it a perfect
fourth power or so that it works out you
know to a nice fourth root but what we
have to do is we have to look at what
we're missing we need actually two more
twos so that'll give us four twos okay
and we also need one more X okay so
that's what I'm going to multiply by I'm
gonna multiply the same thing numerator
and denominator by that same quantity
okay so you're with me so far so if we
were to multiply across what we're
getting is we're getting the fourth root
of two squared times two squared is two
to the fourth X to the fourth and the
numerator we're getting five or through
two let's see two squared is four X and
then here what you can see is the fourth
root and the fourth power these are
cancelling
they're out there inverses so you get to
same thing with the exes you get ex and
the numerator we have five times the
fourth root of 4x and you've got it so
the key is to make the denominator a
perfect fourth root so that you can get
rid of that radical in the denominator
but you want to make sure you do the
same thing top and bottom so it's like
multiplying by one okay last example
here we're dealing with the cube root
now what I would do in a situation like
this where this whole thing is
underneath the cube root is I would try
to reduce first so what I mean by that
is see the 8 and the 32 you can reduce
that to 1/4 write one of these X's
cancels to one of these X's so that's
just going to be X and then one of these
wise cancels one of these leaving 4 left
over in the denominator so now what
we're looking at is the cube root and
notice I'm splitting this up into a cube
root of the numerator divided by cube
root of the denominator so you can do
that and again remember 4 is really like
2 squared okay so let's let's take a
look a little bit closer here so it
looks like we've got a group of 3 wise
okay there's actually 4 here so if we
simplify that we get Y and the cube root
of 2 squared with 1y left over right so
we've made a group of 3 with 1 left over
and then over here cube root of 1 is
just 1 so we just get the cube root of X
in the numerator okay but remember our
goal is to get rid of that radical in
the denominator okay we want to make
sure we have groups of or multiples of 3
since we're taking the cube root so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to multiply
by the cube root of we need another 2
and we also need two more Y's so
whatever I do to the denominator I'm
going to do the numerator okay
and so look what happens we've got this
is going to give us 2 cubed and the cube
root of 2 cubed is just 2 we've got Y
cubed the cube root of Y cubed is y
times this Y gives us Y squared and then
over here in the numerator we've got
let's see 2 X Y squared and that's all
underneath the cube root and that's as
far as we can go so we've got rid of the
radical in the denominator and we
simplified as much as we possibly could
so that's our final answer
and all these examples I was just
assuming that the variables were
positive ok so just make a note of that
these were considered that they were all
positive
and that's it so I hope this helped you
understand how to work with some more
challenging radical examples
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you soon